science mission RNA DNA binding protein  FES is involved in gene expression  regulation associated with ALS and  frontotemporal dementia but the  disease-causing mechanisms are not known  scientists demonstrate that FES  regulates the stability of glue Yewon  mRNA and dendritic maturation and a  place a role in FTL d associated  behaviors next researchers show that  developing cortical neurons have reduced  level of the antioxidant transcription  factor nrf2 due to epigenetic silencing  and that this is necessary for proper  neuronal development next directional  migration of cells through complex  environment like cancer is not well  understood researchers show that auto  crane exosome secretion is required for  persistent and efficient in vivo cancer  motility and promotes assembly of  addition complexes by delivering  fibronectin bound exosomes for more  details visitors at www is my shin calm  and our Facebook page thank you